- "Key & Peele," man,
it's Vandaveon
and Mike again, man.
We really love your shit, y'all.
- Y'alls is
stupid, though.
Y'alls is stupid.
- Shit is funny, dude.
Just want to give
a couple of notes.
You had one scene
in this particular show, man,
it was--it was like, dude...
- Niggas in college.
- These two motherfuckers
in college, right?
And they branding each other
'cause they in
a black fraternity.
Man, watch this, man.
- [shouting indistinctly]
[both screaming]
- What are you doing, man?
- You said upside-down
and to the side.
- That's three Omegas!
- Oh, man,
I forgot the "pi."
Yeah!
- Aah!
- [snickering]
That shit was--
see, they should have--
- That was my shit.
Y'all should have--
- They should have--
should have started
up from there.
- They should have
started there, man.
That's what I was gonna say.
They should have started
with the dick, man.
The first thing,
like, when the lights came up
we should have seen
is a dick on his chest.
- Straight up starting.
- And then y'all should
have just been like,
"Skah, skah, skah,"
just putting dicks
all over the place, man.
Y'all should have put
a dick on a wall.
Another dude should have been
like, "Sss,"
and put a dick on his face.
Another dude like, "Nigga,
I might have a dick on my chest.
You have a dick on your face!"
- Nigga dick on--
put a dick on his dick.
[both laughing]
You got to put a dick
on his dick, tell 'em.
- He talking about--
what's he talking about, "Sss."
"Aah!"
Got a dick on my dick.
He said, "I put a dick
on your dick, man."
- You need to start
with the punch line sometime.
- That's right, yeah.
Another thing would have
been good, man,
is if his momma
had come in there,
"Nigga, what you doing up here?"
"Sss," put a dick
right on her chin.
- Put a dick
on the mom's head.
- She be like, "Oh, no, man..."
- Nigga, you stupid,
that's stupid, that's stupid.
- You know what
I'm talking about,
his momma coming in there?
"I came all the way from home
to visit your ass in college.
What are you doing up in here?"
He be like, "Shut up, bitch."
"Sss," with a dick.
[laughter]
If you had, like,
a third roommate, man.
The motherfucker's outside,
like, with a cup
up on the door like this.
He's like--
- Misinterprets.
- Yeah, yeah, up at the door
of the room, talking about,
"What's, what, what?"
And the dudes are in there,
"Ah, man,
you went crazy, man,
got a dick on my chest."
And the other dude
be like, "Oh..."
Like that, man,
you know what I'm saying?
And then the other dude's
like, "Man, what happened?"
Like, "Sss," "Oh, no, no, man,
now you got a dick on my face!"
And they be like, "What?"
And then, like, the two dudes,
their girlfriends would come by
talking about,
"What's going on, Darnell?"
And Darnell like,
"Shh, shh, shh, be quiet.
Listen, listen,"
and he let them listen.
And they be talking about,
"Oh, man, now you got dicks
all over me."
And the girls be like,
"Oh, no, my nigga gay!"
That's my shit--what?
- Then nigga put
some balls on his ass,
and shit like that.
- [laughing]
Say it, say it.
- Why not?
- Go ahead, say it.
- No, nigga, that's you,
that's all you.
- No, go ahead,
say it, Mike.
- It's all you, son,
that's all you.
- He said he's gonna put
some balls on his...
- I ain't trying
to be in this shit, man.
- And then he can hear him
through the door.
- This nigga stupid.
You being stupid
right now.
Nigga being stupid.
- Oh, man, it was almost
there, like that, dawg.
It was like that, man.
You all were almost there.
But we laughed hard
when we saw that dick, though.
- That shit was funny.